to two things number one is that there
was a worldwide network of people out to
harm us and that was through al-qaeda
Saddam Hussein had a great hatred of the
United States because of the first Gulf
War but even before that would do
anything to hurt the United States
because it had defeated him in 1991 so
wrongly on that and secondly that he had
an active program of weapons of mass
destruction so that he could really do
us harm
not just his neighbors two of whom were
invaded Iran and the Kuwait but he could
do us harm by giving the weapons of mass
destruction and historically we had
known that's Osama bin Laden wanted to
do us harm in the Clinton administration
we had capabilities of taking him out
but we didn't do that because we said we
were unsure and we were just you know
the usual thing of government of
delaying everything and I think that
after 9/11 President United States
wasn't going to just bet on chance that
it would turn out alright when we
learned that we should not have let
Osama bin Laden just continue on his
ways and that wasn't going to happen
again with Saddam Hussein now that
analysis I'm very proud of I think it's
absolutely sound it turned out to be
wrong turned out to be wrong because
there was less of a connection between
Saddam Hussein and the 9/11 or the al
Qaeda but mostly turned out to be wrong
because unlike everything that
intelligence agencies not just the
United States but Germany France and
other countries that opposed the war
told us that he did not have weapons of
mass destruction and I take it from his
lieutenants and all that they were very
surprised that he didn't have weapons of
mass destruction
and presume that he did so the premises
of what we went into were wrong but we
did not know that at the time and we had
no basis of knowing that at the time